the fighter in the kit we've all been
wondering what they think about the pete
davidson louis ck thing
people have been clamoring they're going
these guys put shoes on the table
you're right we should respect them more
these guys put shoes on the table
and i for me i think it's very important
to know what they think of the pete
davidson carlos mata thing
so let's check it out here we go
ck he does it's pretty interesting yeah
he legit reason too
i can tell you i'm not giving away the
joke has especially pete davidson has a
special on netflix come out right which
he goes hard on louis ck he does it's
pretty interesting yeah he
legit reason too it's a legit reason
because you were there brendan i mean it
makes sense
the pete that he sees at the comedy club
he wasn't nice to me yeah
so legit reason too pete with no facts
he's already going into it and by the
way he says here that he's
that he's not going to ruin the joke
spoiler alert mike
does he ruin the joke i can tell you i'm
not giving away the joke
um but he sat down with charlemagne who
does these 101 interviews they're
fantastic
it's on youtube are they are they
fantastic interviews and
uh he's talking about pete davidson by
like you know he dates the hottest
chicks whatever you think he's the hush
oh dude i hate i
i the amount of puss that pete davidson
crushes is bananas brendan schaub and
pete davidson are a race
for me to hate them the most it's like
whoever's speaking is the one i hate the
most that's that
moment yeah it's always changing right
says a huge dick
huge dick did you know that no he's the
originator of big dick energy ariana
grande started that with pete as a huge
[ __ ]
and he seems to be going in on the [ __ ]
too much
he's got a big [ __ ] though royce can we
talk about pete davidson's [ __ ] for a
little more
sure uh he's on saturday night live and
all that they suffer from horrible
horrible depression dude awful
depression talks about how he cuts
himself and all this [ __ ]
is christ yeah and how like on uh
he's got those giant bags under his eyes
he's the nicest guy though man
have you met pete no he's the nicest
[ __ ] guy and everybody hates him like
i wonder why why would you hate it is it
just because he gets a ton of chicks
because he's a douche i'm sorry i'm
sorry
i'm sorry no he's got to figure it out
that's what it is you [ __ ] these guys
man
you're caitlin they're literally
the only reason people don't like pete
davidson is because he has a lot of sex
do you understand that i don't give a
[ __ ]
how many women he [ __ ] he is hateable
you know who else was [ __ ] a lot of
women louie ck
he was [ __ ] a lot of women a lot of
hot broads
someone he was married but he was and
that's fine
you know what i mean good for him but
the
they're they're childish dude it's the
jocks table at a [ __ ] high school
they think oh yeah you just don't like
him because he crushes all that puss
they think the only reason that somebody
doesn't like them
doesn't like pete doesn't like rogan
doesn't like death squad because they're
crushing
it's because of the sex jesus christ
you're simpletons
it's because he [ __ ] all these really
famous chicks i think that has something
to do with it and then
i think it's probably a group of people
who love ariana grande
but why yeah no it has nothing to do
with the fact that he's a [ __ ] hack
he's not funny he's a douchebag
he's [ __ ] douchebag he goes in on
everybody but when somebody goes in on
him he plays the victim
cries like a little [ __ ] yeah he's
[ __ ] gonna do it yeah he [ __ ] has
hand tattoos
but no it's the puss what do you think
he without even trying makes news
and so people that's what he said and he
he was like man i'm not trying no he's
like i just want to be a stand-up and do
something live he's like
[ __ ] that's a lie pete wants to be a
rock star
he lives like a rock star he acts like a
rock star hanging out with rapper he
wants to hang out with you
exactly so don't [ __ ] want to do my
comedy no you don't
you know just wanted to do his comedy
louis ck just wanted to [ __ ] do a
stand up and write shows and check off
in front of girls
jerk off in front of girls with consent
of course all right live
in i get what he's saying he goes on
saturday live he's like
i had to say something to the writing
room because they always made me out to
be like the dumb guy
and i'm a smart dude yeah because you
know like you know smart people always
really want to push how smart they are
right right and they want and you know
every time we talk about pete davidson
pete davidson does have a pretty loyal
fan group and it's it's usually [ __ ]
20 year old [ __ ] dudes or chicks that
like pete davidson and
people that see the loser they are in
peace right exactly yeah
so in every bit i was the dumb guy he's
like obviously i'm not a dumb person but
they made it to me like this he goes and
i'd go on the road to stamp well nobody
wants to pay to see a dumbass
like no one's gonna pay to see a dummy
well how do you expect you selling
tickets
and that's not true at all there's
plenty of dummies that are hilarious
rich voss is an absolute dummy and he's
hilarious
it's one of the funniest meanest
quickest comics out there but you know
what
rich voss for all intents and purposes
is a [ __ ] dumb
but it's very funny and he sells out
everywhere he goes so stop
so louis j gomez is by no means
uh considered a rhodes scholar in any
social circles
people line up to go to those shows
right like there's a lot of comics that
are
dumb in that that they they come off
approachable and not and likable and
people are like ah
bobby kelly is another guy that would
probably be considered
if you put him in a room with a bunch of
[ __ ] mensa candidates he's a [ __ ]
dummy
very funny comic brilliant so stop dude
stop
hurting me you decide to go in the
writing room like no i'm sorry you
couldn't sell yourself
yeah he's like i can't be the dumbass of
every scene i'm sure that i mean now
then
fine but i can't just be the dummy and
everything sure yeah also you know he's
obviously he's having a hard time a lot
of times he doesn't
really he was a comedian phenom dude he
was like 17
yeah doing legit stand up oh my god did
they just suck pete davidson's dick for
this
is what they do it's just dick sucking
it's just all this dick sucking
really and then open for chappelle and
just
because he styled him out when he was i
think like yeah he's on out yeah
he uh he talks about i've always liked
him man
imagine be imagine saying being on while
and out
is a big [ __ ] deal huge imagine
saying that being on
[ __ ] wiling out oh what's up you're
too cool for a while and outrageous
the people that watch while in out get
fed's magazine
[Laughter]
he's super nice i love pete but um
doc's what's that other show the [ __ ]
other show that the
show where they watch youtube videos but
it's on mtv ridiculousness yeah that's
another one
that that's that's a [ __ ] another one
rob deer deck yeah ridiculousness is the
show that's on wherever your molly
dealer lives
like that's what's on the tv yo dawg did
you see that [ __ ] shut up
it's about um again he has a bit out of
it but it opens up a special how
when he's on saturday night live louis
c.k was on there and
you know pete david smokes a lot of weed
because instead of taking prescription
medications
weed helps him calm down and not be so
no he's a [ __ ] pothead let's just
stop with the [ __ ] here he's a [ __ ]
up
i really hate that i i i really hate
that whole that whole [ __ ]
instead of taking this you know three
yeah okay cool again let me guess
instead of [ __ ] taking xanax he cuts
himself yeah
let's be fair here okay smoking weed and
all these people that go nah man it
helps my anxiety no being addicted to
marijuana doesn't help with your anxiety
let's just stop this is a stop right
there
so he's a big advocate for weed so he
was smoking weed
um you know on the set you know that's
what he does lauren michael smokes weed
but not as much as him
he was saying so he was getting high and
that's when louis c.k was hosting
so he says um he gets off the elevator
and louis c.k is like holding court with
all the the cast members
and uh pete just like waves and luis
came from him and goes like how [ __ ]
high
that kid look how high pete davidson
like this [ __ ] cadoos
so goddamn high man smoking his life
away
and pete said he was so isaac that
didn't happen
that's that's not real that's whatever
it gets on the elevator next day he gets
a call from lauren michael's
office he goes which is weird because
i've been here for how many six years
he's telling
the entire joke also i love the fact
that even from pete's own story he's
like
yeah i was so high i doubted that it
even happened
but this guy's a dick for pointing out
that i was that hot right
but you're right and he's making a valid
point he was probably
[ __ ] off his and by the way i also
don't believe that he was just smoking
weed
he was probably [ __ ] up that night in
general and he probably got called out
on it so what
that's life he goes they've never once
called me so that ah [ __ ] here we go i'm
gonna get fired
he thinks he's gonna get fired every
week right listen to this
he's telling the entire sto the entire
bit
he's not gonna spoil it though he goes
up there and lord michael goes hey
wouldn't you know louis ck came to my
office yesterday and asked me to fire
you
let me let you go and laura michael's
like not happening like smoke weed but
maybe just don't
do it as much in front of the guests
stuff like that but do your thing it's
what makes you you
and so pete is like what the [ __ ] man
say he was just a dick to all young
comics he's ever met
he's just louis aka has been that you
know what's going on he's been a dick
his entire life
so his i'm not i'm like notice something
with this story
brian callan's not interested in it well
not only is he not interested brian
callan is not wanting to burn any
bridges he's playing
wow brian callan's not burning any
bridges because brian count has little
tv shows and um
he wants to make sure just in case brian
collins treating brendan job the way you
treat a girlfriend he's telling an
endless story yeah wow that's crazy
here with jo that's the premises but
this joke is you know so then i wake up
one morning
i talk about louis ck jack in front of
women i just go
yes and he goes on this bit but
you know well let's see here's the
difference brennan
you [ __ ] mourn and i get you guys are
kindred spirits you and pete davidson
you're both [ __ ] stupid
except pete davidson has occurred
davidson has the courage to cut himself
um the here's the difference
but louis ck was getting consent from
women to jerk off in his hotel room
pete davidson is at his job getting so
high
he can't remember what the guest host is
saying do you not see the difference not
even
not even can't remember but it just
doubts it even happens
because right so [ __ ] up oh well if
you talk to any young comics that louis
ck is known for that
i'm not telling anything you don't know
especially on new york i'm not saying
there's a reason why a lot of people are
like oh
i'm not saying anything which means
maybe brian callan has said something
about louis before
wow i had no idea well louie from my
experience i've never known
him louie was never a very warm guy or
that
that's one of the issues that seemed
very generous yeah when that's neither
was eddie murphy like
[ __ ] what do they owe you is what i
don't get no but seriously you know who
else wasn't a warm guy richard pryor
like
you know other people you know what is
another guy i never hear stories of
generosity about
brian gallant yeah that's right i've
never heard stories of generosity from
them have you
stuff came out that was one of the
issues is he was just an [ __ ] to
everybody
that was one of the issues yeah
everyone's like [ __ ] that yeah
let them fry you know heard his new
house
kind of the according to reports he was
not known in comedy circles for exposing
himself it's not true
uh and forcing lesser known comedians to
watch a message it's not true that
that's
this is when people started [ __ ]
things up nobody it wasn't known
in fact the did the i mean i've been in
this business a long time did lou ck
jacket off yeah
it wasn't really known that that wasn't
until things started don't have any real
friends
yeah no one tells you anything you don't
have any friends in the business brian i
really
like to tell you anything but it was
kind of a known thing coming out and
then that story came out that there was
one story i know the guy
i i know a lot about it did these these
things get a little crazy but but i will
say that my
experience is you caught it right away
that yeah yeah that that so remember
these are the same guys that when we
were making fun of them
and we are currently still we're making
fun of ghosts that's all you have to do
is criticize other people
that's what their entire show is it's
criticizing other people that's all they
do
what is it what does anybody do what are
you doing what are you what are you guys
doing you're criticizing louie right
sitting around like a bunch of [ __ ]
little uh ladies at the [ __ ] hair
salon yeah
gossiping i think when you're an older
when you're an older comic and you're
established
it's upon you to make it easier on
younger comics
why why no
if you're an older comic your job is to
be a [ __ ] comic
what does it matter i really don't
understand this
it doesn't make any sense to me it
doesn't make any sense is this like
do they believe in some sort of like
comedy socialism
where you have to spread the comedic
wealth
i i yeah i don't know and and i don't
know when
any time like i don't remember a time
when comics were all out here
nurturing each other like it's always
been a competitive field
and louie has but here's the thing this
is this is where this kind of all falls
apart
louie does help comics the ones that he
likes
what watches show louie yeah but that's
that's all of us in life we help the
people we like
yeah it's not up to us to help everybody
and louis does
he doesn't have to give a work
to a guy who's stoned and not taking his
job seriously in his [ __ ] knuckle
tattoos
he probably found pete to be [ __ ]
off-putting
like most normal people like most normal
people they don't go
oh look it's pete davidson louie
probably viewed him through the lens of
a grown-up and was like
[ __ ] is this kid just showing up all
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] and i also don't
believe he contacted
lauren he has he has had
louis ck has had so many
different people let me tell you louis
ck's had comics that he's had on his
show
you ready he's had uh pamela aldalon
he's had todd berry he's had hannah will
burst
young comedian by the way at the time
especially young comedian
uh rick crom nick depaolo robert kelly
dane cook jim norton chris rock jerry
seinfeld
sarah silverman chelsea peretti uh
ricky gervais uh
dane cook i said joan rivers bob saget
doug stanhope
gabby hoffman uh let's see here he's jay
leno david lynch
amy poehler parker posey don't
[ __ ] tell me that he doesn't help
comics out
he doesn't help your little comic
friends out and that's why your butt
hurt
he doesn't help the comics out that's no
that's what it is
he doesn't help the comics out and
because he doesn't help the
comics out louie's a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
are you kidding me louie having a five
minute conversation
at a diner is funnier than both of your
guys's entire catalog
that has to hurt that really has to hurt
you
when deep down inside no matter what you
throw at him and no matter what you do
to louis no matter
what you say about louie whether you
like lu and by the way there's stuff in
that louis doesn't is
politically in his personal i don't
personally like it you know that letter
he wrote oh yeah no he's but
we're talking about sufferables we're
talking about certain areas but yeah
it's got to hurt you
brian and be cool mm-hmm and be generous
and it means the world to young comics
and i both i've seen a lot of comics
through the years
so when you see us brian you're going to
be generous and warm to us
i would hope so you're gonna be warm and
generous gonna be a man of his word
royce you know who else you should be
warm and generous to brian
your wife and kids well it's a little
i'm just saying that ship has sealed
royce and you're just rubbing it in and
that's not nice
yeah you should be warm and generous to
them have you thought about that
hey brendan you know who you should be
warm and generous to the ufc fight
doctor
who has several medical degrees well
it's paying your life and you make him
sound like a ching chong ding dong maybe
you should be jealous to him
be nurturing him hey you know who y'all
should be generous to brendan shane
gillis
the same guy who was doing his thing and
wanted to be on snl
the same show pete davidson is on and
then the moment he got kicked off you
sided with them kicking him off the show
because like yeah man
making fun of chinese people
that wasn't nurturing shane is a young
up and coming comic
that's the problem with you [ __ ] you
guys want everybody in your little
crew you want everybody who buys three
thousand dollar sneakers
to have louis ck buck and be nice to
them you want people that why they still
buy diesel jeans
for louis ck to go hey you wear tight
pants and have a neck tattoo
i'm going to help you out but you can't
just admit that you want something so
then you have to go like man it's just
[ __ ] up you should treat people better
but you don't treat people by this
standards so that's very hypocritical i
hate these
[ __ ] la pieces of [ __ ] i want to take
them all down one by one
who would go up and bump everybody
because they do
two hours not these days though isn't it
you can't really get away with it
anymore i'm not going to be the store if
you tried that
you know if you're getting bad you're
gonna bump well i'm just saying like
let's say someone came up and bumped me
like you didn't bump me i'm the new guy
right yeah they bought me i went to you
i was like
a new guy that parks where only the the
the the
veteran comedians are supposed to park
because you're joe rogan's friend
and that fake humility isn't gonna last
it's not gonna be that way forever yeah
he said oh i'm the new guy eventually
he's gonna start getting cocky and being
like he's already cocky but you know
what i mean he's gonna stop he's gonna
drop the i'm the new guy act too
hey dude blank ex comic bump me
you and rogan or who crit whoever like
they did what
yeah well that's not what we do around
now oh i love this i love this
not what we do exactly but it's no weird
i'm glad you caught that but something
else
rogan daddy rogan will take care of us
if somebody tries to take our hours
daddy rogan will take let me tell you
[ __ ] something you [ __ ] loser
brendan if louis ck went to the [ __ ]
comedy store
or whatever he wanted to do two hours
joe rogan would be like take as long as
you
[ __ ] yes getting me involved in a
beef with him
are you [ __ ] kidding me do you think
that if
[ __ ] dave chappelle showed up and
wanted to do [ __ ] a four-hour special
they wouldn't tell you and you and
[ __ ] everybody coming up behind you
hey man
sorry tomorrow you're gonna have to come
tomorrow dude everybody
what do you want to do so shut the [ __ ]
up
and it used to take me out of it because
i'm their friend but anybody
it used to be like you didn't bump it up
yeah i never did that
ever because you didn't have enough
material brian
or enough clout yeah or enough comedy
could you imagine brian callan bumping
somebody in los angeles
no seriously i can imagine him buying a
bump from somebody
you know yeah i mean yeah i mean
everyone's so nice
like last night i was sitting before i
go on my set and bobby comes up goes
hey you know you belong here yeah you
know you belong here oh
these jobs in my head ew
eww remember comics used to be brutal
to each other and it was hilarious and
they liked each other i'm not saying
they did it
but now this [ __ ] kumbaya [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] hey man hey mike hey mike
look at me
you know you belong here right well yeah
it's half my show
good get out of your head bro you earned
it oh this is
i know hey half mile hey stop naysaying
yourself this is no it's heavy hey
hey i'm not look at me i take
look at me i take half credit for this
you belong here okay good
go ahead thank you it's very very cool
that's really cool that's really cool
good for bob
um cool [ __ ] sweet too
he took his glasses off but he had these
[ __ ] this sweet outfit on
yeah he's got a podcast with santino now
yeah they do it's great i love it yeah
it's not
great it's not great i want to hear it
nobody loves it they uh
the guy put twins obviously from the
movie twins people like oh that's
[Music]
hey hey show's over we don't have to do
this anymore royce
royce we could leave right now if you
want
they can't even yell at us because it's
six o'clock
obviously from the movie twins mike
obviously from the movie twins i think
that's a great way to end this segment i
think that we couldn't have picked a
better way to end a sec